(cop show music)
- [Radio] Car 67,
come in car 67.
- This is car 67,
- we're code five,
- code five,
- nothing to report.
- we've got nothing to report.
(muffled gunshots, screams)
(80's cop movie music)
- How was the party?
- It's dead.
They ran out of punch, so
I gave them some shots.
(both laughing)
- You get them all?
- No.
But Theresa Two did.
(both laughing)
(dramatic music, gunshots)
(guitar riff)
Well I guess I
didn't get them all.
- Yeah, certainly seems like it.
- Well that's why you're
here to cross the T's,
and dot the--
(gunshots)
And dot the I's.
(laughing)
- You done?
- Done with what?
- I mean, one guy,
that's understandable.
But two guys, come on?
(gunshots)
Three guys, come on Chance!
- There was a lot of guys
in there, give me a break.
- Maybe if you took two seconds
to double check your work,
I wouldn't have to always
clean up your mess.
- Oh well maybe if
you did something
instead of sit in the car
and hide like a coward,
I wouldn't have to.
(gunshot)
- I was calling for backup.
God forbid we follow
procedure, just once.
- Procedure, is like rules,
and Chance Blackstreet
doesn't follow the rules, man.
- I know Chance, everyone knows.
But I don't even think
you're trying to be a rebel.
I think you're just too dumb
to know what the rules are.
(gunshot, groan)
You're too dumb to even
kill all the bad guys!
Look at all the bad guys
you're making me kill!
- Okay, now you're just
being hurtful Moses,
you're starting to
hurt my feelings.
- You hurt my feelings
first when you didn't ask me
to storm into the crack
house, you selfish fuck.
You always just run
into the building,
never once do you look back
at your fucking partner,
you piece of dog shit!
(gunshots)
- Moses, calm down okay,
I mean you're getting
a little loopy, you just
shot a lot of guys--
- Maybe I just want the chance
to die in the line of duty.
Just once.
- You've never said
that before man.
- I'm tired of my
kids walking up to me
and asking, "Hey dad,
what did Chance do today?
Did he kill anyone?"
Do you know how much more
they would respect me,
if I was laid up at a hospital
with a bullet in my chest,
and a hole into my bad
ass leather coat to match?
- That coat cost like 85 bucks--
- It's not about the
fucking coat, Chance.
- Listen, you're a
great cop Moses, okay?
And if those kids don't
respect ya, it's stupid.
They don't respect
you, fuck those kids.
- Hey those are my kids man.
- And they're great kids.
I'm just telling
ya, I respect you.
(gunshots, screaming)
Dude, listen.
You're my partner man,
and I know I take you
for granted sometimes,
but that's only
because deep down inside, I
know you'll always have my back.
- I love you, Chance.
- I can't say the same
thing to you Moses because,
everyone I've ever
loved has died.
- That's the nicest thing
anyone's ever said to me.
- That's okay, you know what?
Next time, I'm gonna let
you run into the drug den
all by yourself, okay?
Come on, there ya
go, there ya go.
There ya "go."
There ya "go," let your
feelings "run" free.
Just know Moses when you ever
"hit the bricks" of life,
just keep on "walking" tall.
You gotta "move
along" with your life.
You just gotta spread
those wings and "fly,"
just let it "go," just
let it "go," just "run."
- You're the best cop
in the world Chance.
- Oh, yes I am.
- I love you so much.
- Papa Blackstreet,
yeah there ya go.
No more kisses, just hugs.
As a matter of fact no more
hugs, you're kinda sweaty.